[Music]
[Music]
okay welcome to the final session we
have three speakers this is another
current research topic so we'll be
highlighting three researchers from C
cell we have professor Eric domain
professor Daniela Rus and professor
Scott Aaronson since we've just come out
of a break I want to remind you to turn
off your cell phones I'm with that I'll
turn it over to Eric thanks so I'm Erik
Demaine and I study algorithms and
theoretical computer science and pretty
much anything that's fun and in
particular today I want to tell you
about the science of origami and the art
of origami and how they relate through
computer science so origami starts at
least centuries possibly a millennia ago
and it used to be about folding very
simple things like cranes or maybe a few
cranes out of one piece of material but
these days it's about folding super
complicated 3d forms out of one square
paper no cuts each of these is one
square paper this piece took I think
over a year to fold give you an idea
here are some examples the top three are
all by MIT graduates it's this is a
challenge to fold a sailboat you can
fold sailboat with the sails open or
closed or you can fold a sailboat being
attacked by a giant kraken all out of
one square paper no cuts
that's the crease pattern if you want to
try it out and this is all made possible
thanks to algorithms and mathematics in
particular this is one new approach to
designing origami called organizer it's
free software you can all download it
the input you specify some 3d model
you'd like to make like the Stanford
Bunny you get a crease pattern which you
can put in a square fold it up and you
get this 3d shape which is exactly your
bunny
it just takes about 10 hours to fold but
extremely general and powerful and
pushing the limits of artistic origami
you can apply it to other materials as
well this is folding one sheet of steel
into that same bunny this also takes a
few hours I'll accelerate it a little
bit and you get that so one sheet of
material you can make anything
surface you want so that was Tomohiro
tachi from tokyo folding here at MIT and
i wanted to give you one example of how
origami obviously has a lot to do with
art and sculpture and there's a lot of
interesting mathematics and geometry in
there as well and algorithms and I like
to do both and a group of us like to do
both and it's really fun to work on the
same project both from an artistic
perspective and from a scientific
perspective I want to give you one
example of a project over the last
twelve years called pleat folding that
has gone from art to math to art to math
to art to math to art to master art to
math to art so and I have seven minutes
so here's a very cool folding you should
try it at home you take a square paper
fold concentric squares alternating
mountain and valley the paper folds
itself into this saddle surface which
for a long time people believed is is a
hyperbolic paraboloid more on that in a
moment
we started playing around with this from
the artistic perspective we came up with
an algorithm that given a polyhedron
like a cube tells you how to join a
whole bunch of hyperbolic paraboloids
together to make some 3d surface and so
this generates sculptures using
mathematics as algorithms as a tool to
design new sculpture you can follow a
similar approach of folding concentric
circles instead of squares here you have
to cut a little hole out of the center
you get another saddle surface paper
folds into that automatically and so on
the scientific side we wanted to know
what is paper doing and so we built a
simulator these are photographs of real
pieces of paper and these are our
simulations so we're simulating what's
going on here's an example of folding
concentric hexagons and the simulation
basically the paper wants to bend at the
creases and not bend anywhere else and
this is the natural equilibrium that
physics finds for you or we can find by
simulation now once you have a physical
model of a virtual model of a physical
piece of paper you can make a physical
sculpture of the virtual model of the
physical piece of paper so this is with
3d printed spheres to make a one-meter
static version of that pleated hexagons
so that's a back to the sculpture on the
mathematics I we've been folding
hyperbolic paraboloids probably
thousands of
them over the over about a period of ten
years and people have been folding them
since the late 20s at the Bauhaus but it
turns out it's impossible to fold a
hyperbolic paraboloid if you take this
crease pattern you cannot make anything
it turns out this was quite a surprise
because we've made a lot of them and it
looked pretty good but some things that
you think that may exist in real life
really don't exist mathematically it
turns out what you need to do is add
extra creases in there in order for this
thing to fold up and then you get a nice
3d model and everything works out and so
reality must be cheating a little bit
there back to the art side these are
some sculptures in the permanent
collection MoMA with with my dad Martin
domain and these are based on the
concentric circle idea which does seem
to exist so we've we've switched mostly
to curved creases it's a bit unusual for
the origami world here instead of a
single circle we actually joined two
circles together make a 720 degree loop
and you get a lot of really cool twists
these are again this natural equilibrium
forms of those pieces of paper on the
more scientific sides more on the
architecture side we're trying to by
making small changes to the crease
patterns we can get very a lot of
control over what 3d shapes results in
the equilibrium form so the idea is you
want to build some pavilion you just
print out a sheet make it cell fold and
it pops into whatever 3d form you want
back on the sculpture side and we've
been playing lately with combining
several of these concentric circle
models together joining them at just a
couple of key points and you get even
more control over the 3d form that
results back on the math side so I'm
alternating back and forth here that's
the point we study this is more of a
mathematical idealization but you know
it's really tedious to fold all these
pleats is there some way that I could
fold Mountain Valley Mountain Valley
Mountain Valley and of them in less than
n operations you know that if you make n
folds if you fold a piece of paper in
half n times you get 2 to the N creases
but you get some weird patterns of
mountains and valleys it's not
alternating and I really want
alternating turns out you can get pretty
close n folds you can get about 1.3 3 to
the end
Mountain Valley pleats and that's close
to optimal it's kind of fun although not
practical it's a fun mathematical
diversion this is one of our latest
sculptures to appear at the Smithsonian
David Huffman I imagine most of you have
heard of David Huffman in the context of
codes there in Huffman codes are in
every every mp3 player every compression
device every cell phone I guess and
David Huffman was a professor at MIT for
a while but lesser known as the he well
he was one of the few pioneers of curved
crease paper folding and he designed
these three models in particular most
people have never seen them and we're
working with his family to document all
of his work and try to figure vers
engineer figure out how he designed
these models of figuring out what his
crease patterns were how he came up with
these crazy foldings because they're
really awesome if you were at the
banquet last night you saw this video
otherwise you can watch it on our web
page this is combining glass both my dad
and I are glass blowers with paper
folding and this sort of gives you an
enclosure it constrains how these these
forms open up and so you get more
control over the shape and one very
recent project is combining the paper on
the outside of blasts make it a little
more a little more exciting so that's a
sculpture side I think that's the end of
the little tour from art to math to art
to math to art to math - art to math to
art to master art and we find this a
really powerful way to work because if
we get stuck solving a math problem we
can just build a sculpture to illustrate
why the math problem is hard and then
often we'll want to build some sculpture
you know wouldn't it be really cool if
we could build X and then wait does X
exist is it possible to build X and then
we have to do new mathematics in order
to figure out how to build that
sculpture so we get we get a lot more
productive because we have to jump back
and or because we had the flexibility to
jump back and forth between these worlds
I wanted to show one more fun thing
which you can play with at home at Erik
Demaine org slash
I think so this is a maze folder so if
you want to fold this three-dimensional
maze
that's the crease pattern just print
that out and play around you can you
make whatever amaze you like here and
you can also type in your favorite
message like mit150 and then there's
your crease pattern start with a large
piece of paper I recommend and you can
do it I mean it is really possible to
fold these things here's a simple
example just folding a 5 by 4 maze I
would love to make one big enough for a
rat to run around in let's see what
happens and yeah here's one last
sculpture this come this is a crease
pattern that has little marks on it and
when you fold it down you get
simultaneously yes in three dimensions
and no in two dimensions so I guess
we're a little conflicted the meaning
and that's it thanks
take york our next speaker is Danielle
Ross so Eric gave you a wonderful survey
of these amazing objects that he can
make by hand by folding now what if we
could take those hands away what we can
imagine these sheets making the shapes
that that eric has painfully folded over
a period of up to a year that would
actually take us to a stage where we
would be able to have sheets that would
organize themselves as objects I would
program their own shape and that is a
step closer to our dream of programming
more than just bits to a dream of
programming matter so what would it take
to achieve this this dream well two
things on one hand we have to make
better materials we have to make smart
materials that embed in them actuation
sensing computation communication and
all the electronics infrastructure that
would enable the control of these sheets
and on the other side we need the
algorithmic and control basis for
achieving shapes so in my research and
in my group we have been actually
studying this problem we have created
sheets that have been inspired by
origami and this was done in
collaboration with Eric and here you can
see a sheet that has creases along each
crease there is an actuator we also have
connectors and other electronics
infrastructure and the sheet is able to
be programmed in in this example in two
different shapes one is the boat the
other one is a plane the programs are
generated automatically using a suite of
planners that decides when each actuator
on this sheet will get to move and in
connection with with what other
actuators so there is our there is our
object now you can do other objects you
can do a whole suite of functional
objects using
origami inspiration in this example you
see an origami worm that is made out of
a specific crease pattern and the little
springs on the body of the robot are
actually shape-memory alloy actuators
that enable this robot to function this
robot was printed out of a single sheet
of paper and it was done in a matter of
a couple of hours so let's see I'm
having trouble with technology here
making shapes or programming shapes by
origami is just one way of of
envisioning programmable matter
more generally programmable matter is
achieved when a collection of robotic
modules that are physically connected
have the ability to to self organize
themselves as a functional object and
the subject could be a robot designed
for a specific task for example a
snake-like robot which would be the
optimal way of traversing a tunnel or a
slinky like robot which would be the
optimal way of climbing stairs or a
functional object such as a dog that
might turn into a couch when you're done
playing with it this idea takes us to
the vision of making machines that have
flexible architectures machines that
have the ability to synthesize a third
hand or a second head or an alligator
according to whatever the manipulation
the sensing or all the task needs of the
user are and this is extremely
challenging and exciting the key to
success in this field is is designing
bodies that have the ability to achieve
this kind of shape transformation but
also the algorithmic basis that that
generates the control structure for how
the modules move and so this has been
extremely exciting to me but also deeply
personal because I grew up reading and
dreaming about the barbapapa family now
the barbapapa family is a family of
blobs and these blobs
can change their shape according to
whatever the task they have to do is so
they can turn into cutting tools
when their house is invaded by a giant
beam or they can turn into containers
for collecting things and even even
objects for for cooking so to me working
on programmable matter is like achieving
a childhood dream of building objects
that can change shape like the barbapapa
family I used to dream about so there
are other approaches to creating
programmable matter besides folding and
another one I wanted to explain today is
the idea of smart sense and I imagine I
give you a bag of smart particles also
materials that embed actuation
computation communication and connection
and you tell your bag make me a rabbit
after the back computes a little bit you
reach in the bag and you pull the rabbit
out when you're done playing with it you
throw the modules back in the bag they
return to the collective group for later
use for a different purpose and so we
haven't made smarts and yet but we have
made some smart rocks and the suite of
algorithms that program shapes with
these rocks following a sculpting like
process and in this video you have you
can see our approach to to making shapes
by smart rocks each of the cubes in this
video is a computer inside the computer
there is a switchable magnet which is on
in one configuration off in another each
computer also has point-to-point
connections to in communication to
neighbors and as the communication
system detects neighbors that has the
ability of triggering the connectors on
or off now once you have assembled this
this block of virtual marble or virtual
particles what you can do is that tell
this blog make me a dog and the modules
talk to each other try to decide which
ones in the final shape which one is not
eventually the decision process
converges and robots can then reprogram
their connectors to be off if the
modules are no longer part of the final
object so here's the here's the dog you
obtained by peeling off the spare
material so we have we have not achieved
smarts and yet but we have moved from
rock smart rocks to smart pebbles the
smart pebbles are one centimeter in
diameter very small computers and the
key technology that makes this work is
something we call the electro permanent
magnet and this is what we use for
program connections for communication
and also for transmitting power between
neighbors it's the C component in my
picture so I have shown you several
examples of programming shape and there
are some wonderful applications in in
this field besides making all the
exciting objects that eric has been able
to do for instance making 3d topological
maps so you know where there is a hill
on your bike ride or in general making
on demand tools and objects but the
challenge is going beyond shape the
challenge is imagining these computers
whose material properties you might be
able to program for example mechanical
properties like friction and strength
and also optical properties perhaps
someday we will be able to have
computers that will become our invisible
cloaks ultimately I think this field
will have a great impact on
manufacturing I imagine the robot Kinkos
of 2020 where I go not to print a poster
but to print a robot I tell them what my
robot payload is perhaps to carry a
right radon sensor I tell them what the
endurance of the robot is what the space
it has to work in is and a day later I
go and I pick up my my robot and I pick
up the programming and user interface
environment for it the robot is
fabricated in layers following the same
process we have seen either with a cell
folding sheets where we build these flat
flat sheets with embedded electronics
that have the ability to self assemble
or following some subtraction like
process and ultimately this this new way
of thinking about computation will have
deep impact
on what we think about computation
ultimately in program in the field of
programmable matter resources such as
act actuation sensing internal state
external state become first-class
citizens just like time and space and
what we will need is profound advances
in in how we design computers and how we
think about the theoretical models of
computation that take all these
resources into account thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Danielle
so our final speaker in the session is
Scott Aaronson and at the conclusion of
Scott's talk Viktor will have some final
words to close the symposium
okay thank you so let me apologize in
advance for a lack of origami in this
talk there will be time traveling
quantum computers but it's really no
match so okay so Moore's law I mean
you've all seen this the number of
transistors per chip for example is
doubled about every two years you know
these days mostly just because of the
increasing number of cores on a chip but
you know this is clearly something which
is one of the major things driving the
progress of technology and so raises the
question if we extrapolate into the
future you know where is this going to
lead us right so one obvious possibility
which was think already alluded to in a
Daniela's talk is the robot uprising so
you know Google may have just become
sentient
you know just instruct all of the
computers to connect it to the Internet
to enslave their owners and and so forth
okay this is actually you know I think
you know for from a at least from a
theoretical computer scientist
perspective you know one of the less
interesting things that could happen in
the future and well why do I say that
well because even a killer robot you
know on the inside is still
fundamentally just a touring machine
okay so touring machine is this
theoretical model of computation you
know weighed down by Alan Turing in the
1930s and it pretty much describes the
internal workings of every computer
every Mac PC iPhone you know and so on
that we have today and furthermore we we
know that touring machines have some
fundamental limitations I mean you know
touring started that out showing that
that they can't solve the halting
problem for example but we believe that
they have even stronger limitations than
that so one of the the most famous is
given by the
the conjecture that P is not equal to NP
okay so you're a pious basically the
class of all problems that a touring
machine or sir say let's say a modern
computer could solve efficiently in an
amount of time that increases polynomial
a with the size of the problem NP stands
for non deterministic polynomial time
it's a dumb name but it's the class of
problems for which if someone gives you
the answer then you can recognize it
efficiently okay and questions are these
classes equal all of our ordinary
experience with the world would lead us
to conjecture that they're not okay that
in other words there are problems where
you can recognize an answer if someone
shows it to you but nevertheless finding
the answer yourself could be
astronomically hard famous example is
say the the Hamilton cycle problem I
give you a graph you know the bunch of
connections between vertices and the
question is is there a way to visit each
vertex exactly once is there a path that
does that okay if someone shows you the
path then of course you can check okay
well indeed I guess there was one okay
but if you know you don't know in
advance what the path is and imagine
that there were thousands of vertices
you know well then then trying all of
the possible paths one by one would just
you know take an astronomical amount of
time the the Sun would go cold
you know before you've you've you've
made a dent in the problem okay so this
is a famous example of what's called an
np-complete problem there's known that
so if P is not equal to NP then actually
there can be no efficient algorithm to
on any present-day computer to solve
this problem okay so this is you know
one of the the greatest open problems I
would say in all of mathematics and
science you can see that because it's
done a cameo on The Simpsons okay but
but you know it raises so so assuming we
all believe that P is not equal to NP
you know raises a for me an extremely
interesting question that's driven a lot
of my research which is sort of is there
any feasible way to solve these problems
then
just consistent with the laws of physics
okay so this is no not just a
mathematical question but also question
about what types of computation do the
laws of physics permit okay so you know
you can think of some hypothetical
things that would that would certainly
make these problems tractable so let me
run you through some of my favorite
examples first one is what I call the
relativity computer okay this is a very
simple proposal you would just start
your computer working on some very hard
problem maybe an np-complete one for
example then you would leave your
computer on earth okay you would board a
spaceship which is traveling it very
close to the speed of light go on a
journey you come back to earth billions
of years have passed civilization is
gone all your friends are long dead but
you've got the answer to your
computational problem okay so I know you
can think you know it's interesting to
ask what is the problem with this
proposal you know besides the fact that
you know all your friends are dead okay
well you know actually the answer turns
out to be the amount of energy that you
would need to accelerate to that close
to the speed of light if you want an
exponential speed-up it turns out you
actually need to accelerate to
exponentially close to C which then
implies that you need an exponential
amount of energy which then implies that
your spaceship has to be exponentially
large okay so you're still spending
exponential time you're just pushing it
to a different place okay you know and
this is an interesting example of how
when you take all the what we know about
physics into account what looks like you
know a way to solve sort of you know
np-complete or other intractable
problems quickly may actually vanish
okay we see that again and again no
other of my favorite examples is what I
call xenos computer this would be a
computer that does the first step in one
second the second step in half a second
the third and a quarter second next in
an eighth and so on so after two seconds
has done an infinite number of steps
okay well what's the problem with this
why don't we build this well people
actually do more or less try this then
that they try to overclock their chips
right but the problem when you do that
is that your chip may melt okay
it may overheat and actually the faster
you want to overclock your chip the more
energy you need to cool it and actually
if you try to run your chip faster than
one clock cycle per Planck time which is
ten to the minus 43 seconds then no one
knows exactly what would happen but
according to you know the best current
physical theories are the best guesses
that you would need an amount of energy
which would exceed the so-called
Schwarzschild bound which then actually
implies that your computer would
collapse through a black hole okay so I
like this is sort of nature's way of
telling you that you can't do something
so okay no other of my favorite examples
is the time travel computer where if we
had closed timelike curves then actually
we could sort of create a situation
where just in order to avoid a
grandfather paradox or sort of in order
to avoid a logical inconsistency a
nature would be forced to solve some
very hard computational problem
including for example an np-complete
problem okay and a simple example of
this would be if you went back in time
and told Shakespeare what plays he was
going to write and then he wrote them
and so then you knew what they were and
so on so you know somehow this really
hard problem gets solved of writing
Hamlet for example and yet no one ever
does the work okay so you know this
would be a great thing if we had it you
know so actually I even wrote a paper
about this that John Watcher is pinning
down exactly what you could do with this
sort of closed timelike curve computer
turns out to be P space which we believe
is actually somewhat larger class than
NP actually don't tell my tenure
committee that I wrote this paper
actually but okay um some of them
probably here but alright so so so no
you know but I want to move on and talk
about a quantum computers you know this
is something that on its face sounds
almost as science fictiony as the other
stuff that I've talked about and yet you
know there were experimental groups all
over the world that have been and are
trying very hard to actually build
quantum computers okay so what is this
well this is a computer I hypothesized a
machine that would exploit the laws of
quantum mechanics to solve certain
problems dramatically faster than we
know
to solve them with any existing computer
and the reason it could do that is that
according to quantum mechanics the state
of a physical system say of n bits is
actually a superposition over all of the
possible configurations that those bits
could be in which means that to specify
the state save n particles you may
actually have to write down a vector of
2 to the n complex numbers okay one for
every possible configuration of the
particles so according to quantum
mechanics which has been our reigning
physical theory since the 1920s you know
the the amount of information in a
simple system is tremendous can be sort
of much much greater than classical
physics would weed you to believe and so
maybe we could exploit that to solve
some hard problems in particular Peter
shor who's in applied math here today
showed that in principle quantum
computer could efficiently factor large
integers
unfortunately what have we done today
after you know groups all over the world
including here at MIT have been working
on implementing quantum computers using
ion traps nuclear magnetic resonance
other proposals what we can what we've
done today after about 20 years of work
is to verify using a quantum computer
that with high probability 15 is equal
to 3 times 5 ok so no just the last
thing so some recent work with my
student Alex arkhipov we actually just
this year published a long paper which
is about a new proposal for a very
rudimentary type of quantum computer
which would be built entirely out of
what's called passive optical elements
like beam splitters okay so you would
just generate single photons pass them
through beam splitters you know and then
like mirrors and so forth and then you
would measure where the photons end up
do all of this very reliably but we
don't require any explicit interaction
or coupling between pairs of photons we
thereby bypass one of the main
technological problems to building a
quantum computer now we have no idea how
to factor numbers or you know break
cryptographic codes using this type of
quantum computer but the main point of
our paper is to give evidence that
this rudimentary type of computer can
solve some problem problem of sampling
from a certain probability distribution
that under plausible conjectures is
intractable for any classical computer
ok and there are several experimental
groups that are currently trying to
implement this experiment at least with
four or five photons so I'm looking
forward to seeing them okay so a summary
so from a theoretical standpoint modern
computers are all kind of the same slop
they're all just polynomial time Turing
machines now you know mathematically we
can envision computers that vastly
exceed those we just have to imagine
into existence a closed timelike curve
or whatever okay but you know we're
using quantum computers we now think
that action actually even in the real
physical world we could exceed the
capabilities of polynomial time Turing
machines by a little bit do say some
things like factoring that are
intractable for any present-day computer
but actually realizing that remains an
enormous challenge and I hope that
things like linear optics will help
provide a path toward that so thank you
[Applause]